en la foto de familia de la otan
aparecerán dos nuevos miembros en un
giro histórico finlandia y suecia han
puesto fin a décadas de no alineamiento
militar
hoy los aliados de la otan tomarán la
histórica decisión de invitar a
finlandia y suecia a ser miembros de la
otan agreements con los votos que el
acuerdo ha celebrado anoche por turquía
finlandia y suecia ayuda a tomar hoy
esta decisión quiero agradecer a turquía
finlandia y suecia por aceptar mi
invitación para acoger las negociaciones
para encontrar una forma conjunta para
seguir adelante
ambos países consideraban que unirse a
la alianza provocaría innecesariamente a
moscú las preocupaciones de finlandia
eran estratégicas ya que comparte una
frontera de 1300 kilómetros con rusia
mientras que las de suecia eran más
ideológicas tras la segunda guerra
mundial el país había optado por
centrarse en él diálogo multilateral y
el desarme nuclear la invasión de
ucrania provocó una transición en las
percepciones
muchos finlandeses y suecos consideran
ahora que pertenecer a la otan les
ayudará a garantizar su seguridad frente
a un líder ruso visto como imprevisible
y beligerante según encuestas publicadas
por cadenas públicas de ambos países el
apoyo ciudadano al ingreso a la alianza
ha aumentado hasta alcanzar el 75 por
ciento en finlandia y el 60% en suecia
la adhesión de los dos países tendrá
ahora que ser ratificada por los
parlamentos de los 30 países miembros de
la alianza un proceso formal pero que
podría durar un año esta es la novena
ampliación de la otan desde su creación
en
1949 la última haciendo la integración
de macedonia del norte en 2020